NICK KREEGER: How's
it going, everybody?
I'm here to talk about
TensorFlow and JavaScript
today.
My name is Nick, and this
is my colleague Ping.
And we work on TensorFlow.js
here in Mountain View.
So the traditional thinking
is machine learning only
happens in Python, right?
That's kind of what
everybody thinks about.
But is that always the case?
Has anybody seen this before?
This is something we host on
our TensorFlow documentation.
This is the machine learning
playground, the TensorFlow
playground.
And it was actually built by our
colleagues in the East Coast.
And it was just a visual to put
into some of our ML classes.
And it kind of
shows how data flows
throughout a connected
neural network
with different
activation functions.
And this was a really
popular project we built,
and it was a lot of fun to make.
And we've gained a lot
of traction from it.
So we started to think
maybe it makes sense
to do ML in the browser.
There's a lot of opportunities
for doing ML directly
in the browser.
We don't need any drivers.
There's no CUDA
installation or anything.
You could just run your code.
The browser has a lot
of interactive features.
Especially with over the last
several years of development,
there is access to things
like sensors and cameras
you can easily hook up to
that type of data stream.
And the other great part
about doing ML directly
in the browser is it's
a good privacy use case.
You don't have to send any
user-facing data or any user
data over the wire, over an RPC.
To do inference behind the
scene in your infrastructure,
you could actually just do
that directly on the client.
So coming back to the
TensorFlow playground,
this is about 400 lines
of JavaScript code,
and it was very specifically
typed for this project.
So our team kind of
took this prototype
and started to build
a linear algebra
library for the browser.
This project was
initially started.
It was all open source under--
it was called deeplearn.js.
And we took deeplearn.js
and aligned it
with what we're doing
with TensorFlow internally
with eager execution and that
type of alignment and launched
TensorFlow.js last
April already.
And once we launched it, we had
a lot of really great community
and Google-built products.
And I want to
highlight a couple.
This is one that
we built at Google.
It's called the
Teachable Machine.
This is all done in the browser.
There's like three
labels you can give what
you're training in the webcam.
There's like a green,
purple, and red.
And it sort of highlights
how a basic image recognition
model can run directly
in the browser.
So this stuff all exists online.
You can still find it.
Another community built
a self-driving car
all in the browser
called Metacar.
And this is cool.
You can watch it train,
and learn the inference
in what the car is driving.
People built games.
So this is a web game
that somebody trained with
TensorFlow.js to avoid--
it's kind of a funny animation,
but there's a little dude
running back and forth.
And he's hiding from
those big balls.
And the model is learning
to avoid the balls
all through using TensorFlow.js
and continuing to play.
This one is really cool.
This is a Google project called
Magenta, which does a lot of ML
with audio.
We have a large library
called Magenta.js,
which is built on TensorFlow.js
to do in-browser audio.
This is a cool demo
somebody built.
It's a digital synthesizer
that learns how to play music
and can drive with it.
Another cool example
that just came out is--
this is all community-built
open source.
It's called face-api.js.
So it's a library that sits
on top of TensorFlow.js.
It has a few different
type of image recognition.
It can detect faces
and facial features,
so even, like, toddlers
work pretty well.
So I want to kind
of showcase how
our library pieces together.
There's sort of two main
components to TensorFlow.js.
There's a Core API
and then a Layers API.
And that is all powered
in the browser by WebGL.
That's how we did the linear
algebra aspect for the browser
is we bootstrap all the linear
algebra all through WebGL
textures.
And on the server side, we
actually ship our C code
that we run Python--
or I'm sorry, that
powers TensorFlow Python.
So you get the
high-end CPU, GPU.
And then eventually, we're
working on the TPU integration
story for server side.
And those who have used
Keras, the Layers API
is almost the same as
Keras, very similar syntax.
The Core APIs are OP level.
And anyone who's worked
with TensorFlow SaveModels,
that API will be pretty similar.
OK, what can you do
today with TensorFlow.js?
Well, you can actually just
author small models directly
in the browser.
There is a limited amount of
resources the browsers have,
so we kind of get into
that a little bit later.
But right now, you can do pure
model training in the browser.
You can import
pretrained models,
so this is a model that has been
trained somewhere else, usually
in the cloud or on
some Python device.
And we have a tool to
serialize the model
and then run that inference
in Node or on the browser.
And we have the ability
to retrain models, so very
basic transfer learning.
We can bring in a model.
Anyone who's seen
TensorFlow for Poets,
it's a very similar exercise.
So to get started
with the Core API,
I want to do just a very simple,
basic fitting a polynomial.
So this is a scatter
of some data we have.
And we're going to write
a really simple model
to try to find the best
fit for this plot of data.
It's the classic fx equals
ax squared plus bx plus c.
Excuse me.
So the first line-- this is
all ES6-style JavaScript,
for those who are familiar.
So we're going to import--
@tensorflow/tfjs is the
name of our package.
And we namespace it as tf.
Now, our first
step is to include
three different
variables-- a, b, and c.
And we actually
initialize those as 0.1.
This is going to be passed
into our training sequence.
The next step to do is
declare our function.
So this is all using the tfjs
APIs are doing that f of x
equals ax squared plus b
to the power of x plus c.
And we have some sugar to
make that a little bit more
readable using chainable
APIs, which is a very
common pattern in JavaScript.
Next step is to declare
a loss function,
just have a mean squared loss.
And then we declare
the SGD optimizer
with a default learning rate
we've declared somewhere
in this code.
And then finally we loop
it through our training.
So EPOCHS we pass through,
and every step, we
minimize our loss through
the SGD optimizer.
This is very similar
to eager-style Python,
for those who have done
that in the Python plane.
Next thing I want
to highlight is
the next step up-- that
layers, that Keras-style API.
And to do so, we've been working
on doing audio recognition
directly in the browser.
And I want to highlight just
simply how that kind of works.
So really simple spoken
commands like up,
down, left, right can
be run through FFT
to build a spectrogram.
So we take audio
in, and we build
a spectrogram as an image, and
we train our model on that.
And we can actually build that
convolutional network pretty
simply with our Layers API.
And the first step is just the
same as our fitting polynomial.
We'll include the package tfjs.
And then we're going to
build a sequential model.
This is very Keras-style.
Excuse me.
Our first step is
to do a conv2d,
a couple of different
filters, and kernelSize.
ReLU activation
functions-- again,
this is very familiar for
those who have used Keras.
Then we have a pooling layer.
And then we're going
to go ahead and do
some more conv2ds, and another
max-pooling level, and so on.
We repeat as we work
our way down the funnel.
And finally, we flatten out
our layers, add some dropout,
add a large dense layer at
the very end, one more dropout
layer, and then finally, our
softmax for audio labeling.
And finally, let's
compile the model.
So this is again,
very similar to Keras.
We're going to compile
our model that we built.
We'll know any errors
that we have as the model
is constructed.
Give it an optimizer,
and then we
call model.fit to start
passing in our training data
with our labels.
And once the model has trained,
we can save it to disk.
We have options for saving
directly in the browser
and on a Node.js to file.
And then finally, we can use
that model to do prediction.
So we model.predict, and
we pass in our spectrogram.
OK, so those were two quick
passes at some of the APIs we
use-- the higher-level Core
and then the lower-level--
I'm sorry, the higher-level
Layers API and the lower-level
Core API.
But one of the cool parts
of doing the browser
is we can take in models that
have already been trained today
and build interactive demos.
And for that, I want to
showcase a small video.
This is actually built
by a collaboration
of the TensorFlow.js team and
a Google internal design firm.
And we've built this
game for mobile devices.
And it uses MobileNet to
do an emoji scavenger hunt.
So in the game, the game
will suggest an emoji.
And you have to run
around the office
and find it with your
webcam on your phone.
And this is all doing inference
that's powered directly
with the browser.
For this one, I'll
play a quick video,
and it will kind of
give you a better
highlight of what's going on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is an umbrella.
So is this.
This is a slice of pizza.
Emojis have become a
language of their own.
We use them everyday to
communicate in our texts
and emails, so much so
that it's easy to forget
about the real-world
objects they're based on,
which got us thinking.
Could we create a game
that challenges people
to find the real-world versions
of the emojis we use everyday?
Introducing "Emoji
Scavenger Hunt."
"Emoji Scavenger Hunt"
uses TensorFlow.js.
Open source meets
machine learning
meets JavaScript meets fun.
It works like this--
we show you an emoji.
Use your phone's camera to find
it before the clock runs out.
- Hey, you found pen.
- Find it in time and you
advance the next emoji.
While you're searching,
you'll hear our machine
learning system doing its thing.
- Do I see a toilet tissue?
- Hey, do you have a watch?
- Was that a tub?
Is that a glove?
Hey, you found a watch.
- See if you can find all
the emojis before the timer
runs out.
- Do I spy a broom?
- "Emoji Scavenger Hunt"--
powered by machine learning.
Start your search at
g.co/EmojiScavengerHunt.
- Do I see a URL?
[END PLAYBACK]
NICK KREEGER: Cool.
So that sort of showcases
where someone has already
done the hard work
of training a model.
Now, we can build that
great interactive demo.
OK, so I want to
highlight how we actually
do that behind the scenes.
So the first step is taking
that pretrained model.
This is MobileNet.
It's been trained under
Python TensorFlow.
Internally in MobileNet,
those who have used MobileNet
will know there's an object
detector that you can
tune for a specific labeling.
And then we import that
into our JavaScript app--
the scavenger hunt.
The first step once the model's
been trained, we save it.
There is a few different
paths for doing this.
There's the traditional
TensorFlow saved_model API.
And we also support
Keras as well.
So there's a sequential
MobileNet model for Keras.
Then we have a conversion step.
So this is a tool
that TensorFlow.js
ships over Python.
It's a pip install
tensorflowjs, and you can
use the tensorflowjs_converter.
For interacting
with a saved_model,
there's a couple
different options
for finding the output
of the inference graph
and where we want to
serialize our artifacts.
And then we also support
the Keras-style converter
as well for HDF5 file format.
And finally, we would like
to load those artifacts
into the browser.
So this is all JavaScript code.
For that saved_model,
it's tf.loadSavedModel.
And we have two
different artifacts
that our script creates.
There's a weights link and
then a link to the JSON file,
which describes the
inference graph.
And again, there's
the Keras-style one.
Keras actually ships
all-in-one JSON file,
which has one downside of it
avoids some of the caching
that we provide
for saved_models.
What happens in that
model conversion step?
So the first thing we do--
especially, like
saved_model has a lot
of different paths
for the graph.
There is an inference graph,
which is the one we want.
There's steps for training.
And a lot of time, if you're
using the tf.data pipeline,
there's actually graphs
for all the data ops.
So we actually pull out
the graph for inference,
and then collapse ops as needed,
and run some optimization.
And the one other great
thing we do for a saved_model
is sharding of weights into 4
megabyte chunks, which cache
nicely with modern browsers.
So it's only a one-time fetch
for those larger models.
And we support about 120 plus
of today's TensorFlow ops
in that conversion step, and
we're always adding more.
And again, the TF/Keras
Layers are supported
with this conversion step.
I also wanted to
showcase one more demo.
This is a newer demo that
we've just shipped this summer.
And it's using PoseNet, which
is a human estimation demo.
And for this, I'm
going to hand it
over the Ping, who is
going to highlight this.
PING YU: All right, guys.
So PoseNet is another
example of converting
a Python-trained model and
loading to the browser.
So on the right side, you
can see a lot of control
that can fine-tune the model.
And on the left side is
a live feed of a video.
So in the video, you can see you
can detect my face features as
well as my body parts.
So this is a collaboration
between a Google research team
as well as external contributor.
So this model is in
our model repository.
You can check them out.
On the left side, you
can see actually it
has about 15 FPS,
so Frame Per Second.
You can build some
cool application,
like build recognizing
motions for sports, et cetera.
We also have other models
in that repository,
so like audio command model
that Nick mentioned earlier.
And also we're adding some
other, like object detection
model.
So all of that is available
for you to use in the browser.
Just go ahead, check
them out, and let us know
if you build any cool apps.
Thanks.
NICK KREEGER: And the great
part about that is it's
feeding directly off of the
camera feed in real time.
And we're doing about
15 frames a second
and presenting over the
USB-C, so it does pretty well.
OK, so I did mention earlier
about training directly
in the browser.
This is the retraining--
the transfer learning step.
And for this, we have
another cool demo
that we want to showcase.
Again, we're using MobileNet.
And Ping is going to pull this
demo up while I'm talking.
So we built this demo where
we have a baseline MobileNet
model that we've
loaded in the browser.
And we're going to train
Ping's face to play Pac-Man.
So he's going to start
collecting samples
from the webcam of what
his up, down, left is.
And so for this, he's
going to use his face.
So as he's moving
his face around,
he's collecting
different samples
that we're going to pass
into that retraining step.
So there's an up,
down, left, and right.
And with this demo,
as you hold down,
we're collecting
more and more frames.
He's getting close, OK.
And then now that he's
collected his frames,
he's going to click
the Train Model button.
And we'll watch our last
shoot straight down.
It only takes a couple seconds.
And now, he's ready
to play Pac-Man.
So go ahead and hit
Play there, Ping.
PING YU: All right, let's go.
NICK KREEGER: All right.
There you go.
So the model is running
directly in the browser.
We've retrained it to
those pictures of his face.
And the controls are lighting
up left, down, right based
on what the model is doing.
PING YU: Aw, come on.
NICK KREEGER: All right.
So this is a great
use case of what
you could do with
taking advantage
of some of the stuff the browser
provides in doing accessibility
for machine learning
and building cool apps.
OK, Ping, we can
play Pac-Man all day.
PING YU: I got this.
NICK KREEGER:
These demos are all
available on our site, which
we'll showcase at the end.
You can actually
just run this today.
No drivers, no
anything to install.
OK.
PING YU: Let's go.
NICK KREEGER: Cool.
All right, so I've showed
off a bunch of demos
using our Core API,
using that Layers API,
bringing in pretrained
models and doing
some basic retraining.
So where does performance
kind of step up--
stand for TensorFlow.js
for our browser runtime,
that WebGL-powered runtime?
So this is some
benchmarks we've done
using Python and MobileNet.
So there's two computers that
we use for these benchmarks.
The top one is a high-end
workstation with a 1080
GTX, the high-end NVIDIA card.
So it's super fast, a
little under 3 milliseconds
for our inference time.
And then we used a 13-inch
MacBook with a nonintegrated
graphics card--
or with a integrated graphics
card, not a standalone graphics
card.
And that was using the
CPU build so there's no--
it's just the default
AVX instruction
step we ship with TensorFlow.
And we doing a little
under 60 milliseconds
for inference time.
So where does the TensorFlow.js
benchmark stand up?
Well, it kind of depends.
On that super beefy 1080
card, we're really close--
about 11 milliseconds
per inference time.
The CPUs they're running on this
laptop is a little bit slower.
It's a little under
100 milliseconds
per inference time, but that
was still giving us that
15 to 20 frames per second,
which allows you to still build
interactive demos.
So this discussion leads
us to our next part,
which is where does
TensorFlow.js on server-side
come into?
We think there's a lot
of great opportunities
for going with JavaScript ML on
the server-side under Node.js.
The ecosystem for Node
packages is really awesome.
There's tons of
prebuilt libraries
off the shelf for npm.
You can build applications
really quickly
and distribute them on all
these different cloud services.
The default runtime for
Node.js V8 is super fast.
It's had tons of
resources put into it
by companies like Google.
And we've seen benchmarks where
the JS interpreter in Node
is 10 times faster
than the Python.
By enabling TensorFlow
with Node.js,
we actually get access to
that high-end hardware--
so those Cloud TPUs,
the GPU, and so on.
So those are all
exciting things.
I wanted to showcase
one real simple use
case of Node.js and TensorFlow.
The code snippet I have
up here on the screen
is actually a really
simple Express app.
If anyone's used it, it's just
a request response handler.
And we just handle
the endpoint /model,
which has a request and a
response that we'll write out
to.
So this model,
right now actually,
we have a model
that we've defined.
And we're going to do some
prediction on input that's
been passed into this endpoint.
Now to turn on
TensorFlow.js with Node,
it's one line of code.
It's just importing the binding.
So this is a binding
we ship over npm.
And it gives you
the high-end power
of TensorFlow C library, all
executed under the Node.js
runtime.
And what can you do
today with server-side?
So all those demos
we showed of running
the model in the
browser, those actually
just run under Node as well.
You can use our
conversion script.
We ship the three
major platforms--
MacOS, Linux, and Windows CPU.
And we also have GPU and
CUDA for Linux and Windows.
We just launched
Windows late last week.
And all of the full
library support--
so the Layers API and our
Core API all work today right
out of the box with Node.js.
And to kind of highlight how we
can bring all these components
of npm and TensorFlow.js
and Node.js together,
we built a little
interactive demo.
So I know not everybody is
super familiar with baseball,
but Major League
Baseball Advanced Media
has this huge dataset where
they record using sensors
that all the stadiums, the
different types of pitches
that players throw at games.
So there's pitches
that are really
fast that have a high
velocity and low movement.
And then there are pitches
who are a little slower that
have more movement.
So we curated this
dataset and built a model
all in TensorFlow.js that
trains against this data
and detects, I
think, seven or eight
different types of pitches.
And it renders it
through a socket.
So don't get too hung up on
the intricacies of baseball.
This is just really solving
a bread-and-butter ML
problem of taking sensor
data and drawing up
a classification.
So for this, I'll have
Ping run through the demo.
PING YU: OK.
All right, so for
web developers,
you could really
use TensorFlow.js
to build a full-stack
kind of ML application.
So on the left side is a
browser that I started a client
on the browsing side
of the browser, which
is trying to connect to the
server through socket.io.
On the right side,
I have my console.
I'm going to start
my Node.js server.
Immediately, you see that it's
binded to our TensorFlow CPU
runtime.
And as it goes, the
model is getting trained.
And the training stats are
fed back to the client-side.
As the training progresses, you
can see the accuracy increase
for all labels.
The curve ball has about
90% accuracy right now.
With server-side implementation,
it's easy to feed new data,
not like inside a browser.
It's much harder.
Let me try and
click this button.
What this will do is I
will load live MLB pitch
data into this application.
And we will try to
run inference on that.
So let me click on that.
So immediately, you
can see the orange bar
is the prediction accuracy
for all of these labels.
Some of them we actually did
better with the live data.
It's 90% for changeup.
Something we did a little
bit less accurate--
fastball 2-seam is only 68%.
So overall, I think
it should demonstrate
that the model actually
generalized pretty
well for the live data as well.
So, yeah, back to you.
Cool.
NICK KREEGER: All right.
I'm going to actually kill that
demo or my laptop will die.
Great.
So just highlighting exactly
what is going on there,
there was the Node.js server
which was doing our training.
There was a training
dataset and an eval dataset,
which we were reporting
back over socket.io
how good we are at each
class through our evaluation.
And then we had the ability
to just easily reach out
to MLB Advanced
Media through Node
and parse through
their data, and then
send in that to the model,
which was the orange prediction.
So kind of a cool use case
of training my model, how
does it stack up
to real-world data
and doing like a
quick visualization.
And that was all plain
JavaScript, plain HTML.
And all the source code
we've shown you today--
all the examples we've shown
you today are open source.
And we'll link to
them at the end here.
So performance--
so I highlighted
where the WebGL runtime
kind of stacked up
with that Python benchmark.
So let's step in and
look at Python benchmark
against the Node.js runtime.
So again, these are
those initial benchmarks
that I highlighted.
The Node runtime itself is just
as fast as the Python runtime
for inference of MobileNet.
This is because we're using the
same library that Python uses,
and there's not
much code to get to,
and then we're running
all that high-end code.
OK, I've highlighted
a lot of stuff
we've built since basically
this year and launched in April.
The Node stuff has been
out since the end of May.
So what's next?
What's the direction
that TensorFlow.js
is looking to go in?
We have some high-level
bets that we're doing.
There's a project
that's going on
that we're going to release
here very soon in the next month
or so.
It's our visualization library.
So it's the ability to
pull in through the browser
and do quick visualizations of
your model in the data we have.
So look for that coming soon.
We also have a full data API,
so very similar to the tf.data.
It'll be browser
and node-specific,
so there will be
convenience functions
for I just want to read
data off of my webcam
and not convert it to tensors.
This API will
provide that for you.
And on the server-side, it will
be giving highly-optimized data
pipelines for doing
Node.js training.
And so those are our
two high-level things.
Those are the big
projects that kind of
cross both of our runtimes.
Looking forward for the browser,
we're working on performance.
So those benchmarks that
I showed with WebGL,
a lot of them are the
bottlenecks or limitations
for WebGL.
So we use 2D textures that
render the tensor data.
There's some bottlenecks for
downloading those textures,
reusing those textures.
So we're working on
WebGL optimization.
We're also adding
more and more ops.
Lately, the focus has been
audio and text-based models.
So we're adding a lot more
ops to help with that.
We have a great stable library
of image recognition ops
and the audio stuff is coming.
And the other thing
we're looking at
is helping push that spec.
So the WebGL runtime
was really interesting,
and it kind of helped
bootstrap ML in the browser.
But WebGL isn't the
best use case for this.
And we're looking at a
few different options.
One is Compute Shaders,
which is much more
similar to a
CUDA-like, where I can
allocate the right
amount of GPU memory
I need to use and do that.
And we're also following
closely the WebGPU spec.
So there's a bunch of different
offerings from Chrome,
and Internet Explorer,
and the browser
vendors for what we want to do.
We're sort of helping
watch that space
and provide guidance as needed.
And on the Node.js
side, cloud integration
is a thing we're looking at.
This includes the
serverless-type integration
points, integration with
our TPUs, and so on.
We're actually
working on generating
op code to provide all the
core TensorFlow ops in Node.js.
The Python version of
TensorFlow, most of the code
is actually generated from
our op registry internally,
so we're writing that for
TypeScript for JavaScript users
too.
And we're providing a better
async support with libuv.
So libuv is the
underpinning in Node.js
for asynchronous programming.
We're working better to make
that scheduler work much nicer,
so we're not blocking as much
main application threads.
OK, wrapping up-- we've
shown you a lot of stuff.
I kind of want to step back and
highlight a couple of things.
First one is our Core API.
That's the bread and butter
of the TensorFlow.js suite.
It's our op library.
It allows you to
interact with tensors.
And we also have our
Layers API, which
is our Keras-style
API for training.
And we also support SavedModel
and Keras model conversion
today through our
converter script.
And the newest runtime
we have is Node.js.
We've just got done talking
about a bunch of that.
And with that, I want to
thank you guys for attending.
Everything I've shown you
is on js.tensorflow.org.
We have quite a bit
of stuff up there.
There's all those
demos that I showed.
They are linked in that page,
so you can find them as well as
the source code.
We also have a variety
of GitHub repos.
Everything we do is on GitHub.
tensorflow/tfjs is our root one.
That's our union package.
We keep track of all of
our GitHub issues there.
It also links out to a
variety of things we have now.
We have an examples
repository, which
has maybe 10 to 15
examples you can just run.
There's also a link
to our models view.
So this is models that we've
pretrained, packaged up
for JavaScript use,
and published over npm.
A lot of them actually
have wrapper APIs,
where you don't even have
to take data and convert it
to tensors and then pass
it in for inference.
It just says here's
an image HTML canvas.
Can you do a prediction?
So those are really cool.
All that stuff is
linked on tfjs.
We also have a gallery too
of community-built stuff,
and it's always growing.
This is our community
mailing list you could also
find on our website.
There's a lot of good discussion
of for how do I do X, Y, and Z,
or I need this feature.
Can you please help?
The gallery repo
I just mentioned,
that's where all of our
community-built examples live
and models repo.
And that's all.
[APPLAUSE]